la mobilisation se voulait symbolique
éprouvés par plus de trois mois d'une
crise sanitaire sans précédent
les soignants appelé ce mardi à défendre
leurs conditions de travail leurs
salaires et obtenir davantage de moyens
pour l'hôpital public
des rassemblements soutenu par les
syndicats
on attend une revalorisation des
salaires et la reconnaissance des
qualifications
on attend que la une ouverture de li lé
embauche de personnel la réouverture
d'hôpitaux et ne pas considérer que
l'argent qu'on met à l'hôpital c'est une
dette augmentera ses investissements et
donc faut arrêter de parler de dettes à
l'hôpital car on sait qu'on a une
politique défaillante au terme des
niveaux de rémunération de carrière et
notre camarade sont mobilisés dans ses
négociations pour obtenir justement des
résultats et consent ou n'arrête pas
remerciements aux applaudissements et
aux paroles et que cela se réalise bien
concrètement bordeaux lyon marseille
nantes
au total 220 rassemblements étaient
aussi prévus dans tout le pays
à paris alors que la manifestation avait
pourtant commencé dans le calme
des échauffourées ont éclaté dans
l'après midi au moment où le cortège
parti du ministère de la santé arrivé
sur l'esplanade des invalides
le rassemblement a viré à l'affrontement
avec plusieurs manifestants jets de
projectiles véhicules dégradés incendie
de mobilier urbain des violences
auxquelles les forces de l'ordre ont
répliqué avec de nombreux tirs de gaz
lacrymogène sur ces images également une
blouse blanche violemment percuté par un
groupe de police une situation chaotique
qui a créé la consternation dans les
rangs des soignants ça m'attriste
profondément
parce que depuis le début tout se passer
correctement c'était une manifestation
bon enfant on sait faire entendre et en
arriver à attaquer les forces de l'ordre
je suis pas sûr que nous ça nous serve à
quelque chose
nous les forces de l'ordre en les voies
quand on passe à côté alors on les salue
on a du respect pour eux voilà est allé
leur foncer dedans ou leur balancer des
plus directement c'est inacceptable ça
fait quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie coville de voir
que des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
les soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
des incidents très violent qui ne
devrait toutefois pas faire oublier le
combat des soignants alors que le ségur
de la santé doit concrétiser d'ici début
juillet le plan massif d'investissements
et de revalorisation promis par le
président emmanuel macron l'ensemble du
corps médical compte bien poursuivre la
mobilisation